make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and uh
make sure you guys hit the like button
if you enjoy the video and yeah
let's begin
okay so we are back with our coverage of
the x-men and it's tuesday which means
it's our day for ongoing videos the
videos that we split into parts this is
the day that we do those when we're
covering marvel comics monday is dc
comics so here's the thing right we are
continuing judgement day and this story
is amazing momentum dude check this out
okay so we actually get a countdown here
now one thing to know everything that
you're gonna see in this comic takes
place over the span of one hour so what
this does is this initially picks up on
the planet of morocco right the great
ring now one thing to remember the great
ring is a rocco's version of the quiet
council from krakow for those of you
guys who are unfamiliar with that the
quiet council on gracoa is basically the
governing body of pretty much all the
earthbound mutants that we're aware of
when you had like the whole ten of
swords event and jonathan hickman's
x-men run and you ended up learning that
there was like a whole other dimension
that had all these mutants that were in
it instead of them residing on earth
with the regular x-men in krakowa they
basically took off to mars that a rocco
the the great ring is their governing
body that one of the things to know is
that the great ring is composed
exclusively of omega level mutants there
are no mutants on here that are not
omega level in power that's why you have
isca the unbeaten it's why you have
cable magneto different people like that
and then you actually have mutants that
are from oracle so aura serrata
ludos logos people like that who's
actually going to be really important as
we get further into the story but one of
the things that happens here is abigail
brand shows up literally with one minute
left and basically tells them like okay
there's a war breaking out between the
eternals the avengers and the x-men just
so you guys know we need to have some
kind of involvement in this right we
need to send our forces to earth in
order to ally with the curcumin mutants
to basically defeat the eternals because
the eternals are so astronomically
powerful and then defend off against the
x-men now one of the things to know is
that abigail brand's presence here is
not really welcome technically speaking
she is the director of sword the
sentient world observation and response
department but much like nick fury when
it comes to shield she's kind of shady
and the thing about this is that she
actually wanted to install spies in
morocco that would basically feed her
information which basically became
public knowledge but the thing about
this is that as she's basically
communicating this message and actually
saying that one of the things that
happens is you basically get this
prophecy right now what had happened
here somewhere along the line is you had
what was called idle the seer right
she's basically a rocco's version of
destiny from the x-men comics on krokoa
she can see the future and she's an
omega level mutant the difference here
is that she at some point lost her
tongue and so she can't actually speak
what it is that she sees they kind of
rely on her silence right her the kind
of silent messages she conveys in order
to interpret things and so what had
happened is she had basically revealed a
prophecy right she says an empty heart
beats hardest an empty hand deals the
impossible blow and the stalemate ends
with victories lost that prophecy is
probably going to become incredibly
important later on down the line it will
become important for this segment here
but that may end up playing like a major
role over the course of the story but
again these guys don't know that they're
on a timetable right one minute 49
seconds 48 seconds 30 seconds right the
clock is counting down and it's one of
those things where they're just kind of
having this conversation like okay well
i mean who in the world are we gonna
send you know it's just for them it's
just kind of general business for the
great circle but then suddenly a blue
light emanates out of nowhere and
they're like what in the hell is that
and that's when you get the arrival of
uranus now one of the things that
happens here is they say okay the war
has reached our doorsteps what is what's
the chance that we have of winning and
iska turns on them and then kills one of
the members of the of the great circle
now one of the things you remember iska
the unbeaten can never lose her mutant
power is that whatever she does will
basically guarantee her victory or
guarantee the victory of the side she's
on now it can be manipulated that's what
we saw when we had that tournament that
was going on before when you had that
fight taking place between scar and you
had a magneto so like it can be
manipulated it can be tricked in this
instance though what she's doing is
designed to illustrate that they're all
going to die right they're all basically
going to fall now the only person who
really looks at the situation and comes
to the realization that the only way to
truly win is to defeat iska right to
basically kill iska the night crawler
teleports over and then takes her off
the board with the intention of
basically taking her out but when that
happens once he teleports away with isca
then you've got the arrival of uranus
right the grandfather of thanos now
here's the thing that i want i want to
make this perfectly clear when it comes
to uranus he's one of the og eternals
the original eternals old school right
depending on how marvel does this it
could very well be that uranus is more
powerful than thanos but he literally
says like like mutants you have excess
like you are excessively deviating and i
have one hour to correct you because
remember mutants are basically the
result of the deviant gene entering the
human bloodstream it's one of the great
big huge changes that marvel's making
which i absolutely love i think it's one
of the coolest things but it's kind of
nuts because within the span of 30
seconds uranus kills 11 000 mutants like
that right in the span of 30 seconds and
the way in which he does this is that
it's not simply just an attack on oracle
one of the things that had happened here
is that druid who's currently the prime
eternal when he released uranus he also
released his weapons cache and so what's
happening here is that earth and mars
are not the only places across the
universe where mutants reside that some
of those mutants from morocco actually
left mars and took off into the universe
they created settlements on other
planets different things like that and
so what you have is the forces of uranus
albeit you know autonomous drones or
what have you who are showing up at
these different locations and
eradicating all these mutants in all
these places for example in the skies
above port prometheus that's where these
things show up right in these locations
all these different spots right the
valley of the fallen and so on and so
forth different places across the
universe so in a lot of ways it is quite
literally a universe-wide conflict now
one of the crazy things that goes on is
that six minutes into this right this is
six minutes in that what you have here
is oraserada that uses her eye on uranus
now one of the things to remember is
that or serrata is an omega level mutant
that when she looks at something they
basically cease to exist she's
essentially an ultimate nullifier right
literally it's as if they never existed
in the first place it doesn't work on
uranus it has no effect on him
whatsoever and so for whatever reason
that's not explained here this guy
survives the entire experience and then
takes aura out following that one of the
things that happens and this is a crazy
moment which i hope we actually get to
see later on down the line legion shows
up now legion's showing up here here's
the thing to remember when you're facing
off against legion you're not just
fighting one omega level mutant you're
fighting a legion of omega level mutants
right you're just fighting as many
powers as he has because remember legion
has all kinds of personalities there's
susan and sunshine there's the origamist
there's all kinds of people there right
there's all kinds of abilities that can
manipulate people in differing ways when
these different personalities take over
legion himself just david holler on his
own is an omega level telepath and
telekinetic he's wildly powerful the
downside to this is that we basically
end up seeing uranus take off with
legion the two of them fight and then
uranus comes back literally the next
page we don't actually see what happens
between the two of them in this conflict
but nonetheless this is when you get to
see like the full-on power of magneto
and like one of the one of the greatest
moments in the history of magneto so one
of the things that goes on here right
god is ridiculously amazing one of the
things that happens here right while you
have literally these forces that are
going through right these forces of
morenos that are attacking in all these
different locations you have the forces
of morocco that are fending off as best
they can and then you actually have
richard ryder nova who's actually
helping to defend the araco mutants to
the best of his ability but ultimately
he just can't seem to pull it off he
just doesn't have the power to do it on
his own i mean he can hold off but in
the end like ultimately these mutants
are going to fall but one of the things
that happens is that magneto enlists
lotus logos now this guy is ridiculously
cool this guy can manipulate any form of
metal in existence and in fact he can
actually produce metal from his own
physical body which in doing so magneto
just enlists that ability from him right
like this guy's feeding magneto metal
and magneto is using it on arenas and
literally just like puncturing this guy
trying to encase this guy the whole nine
yards literally wraps him in metal
shards keeping this guy held in place
and uranus breaks out of it anyway right
like this is 13 minutes in these guys
are falling like flies and in fact
uranus walks up on magneto and just
punches a hole in his chest and kills
magneto on the spot and so one of the
things that happens is that cable tells
his computer right he says body slide by
zero weapon cache omega one it's this
weapon that he has this giant gun right
the omega one pulse rifle that is the
most powerful gun in cable's arsenal now
one of the things to remember is this
has to be provided in context because on
its own it's just a giant gun that cable
has rahu why is that special because one
of the things to remember is that cable
comes from a time when apocalypse rules
the world so this weapon was designed
for the purpose and could have
completely eradicated apocalypse cable
uses this and he fires it on orenos and
nothing happens right he keeps firing it
to the point that it overheats and it
doesn't affect uranus at all that's the
power of uranus right the fact that this
weapon which could just annihilate
someone like apocalypse who uses
celestial technology that it has no
effect on this sky whatsoever and the
falls keep coming right like the deaths
just keep happening that uranus just
keeps killing every single mutant he
comes across annihilates all of him me
takes out abigail brand now here's the
crazy thing while all of this is
happening fisher king is just observing
right he's literally just in his home
and he's aware of it taking place i
remember he's a baseline human but the
big on running theory here is that
fisher king was not introduced for no
reason he was not introduced for no
purpose at all that in fact in the face
of all of this right the eradication of
all these mutants that are dying across
the entirety of morocco that fisher king
is going to basically activate a subset
kind of like a fail-safe protocol for a
handful of mutants that we simply just
didn't know about it's one of the things
that people are speculating of is going
to be a kind of like super secret inner
circle so kind of like a black ops team
which i'm excited to see if that's going
to be the case but one thing that i want
to hit out here uranus had one hour to
eradicate as many mutants as he possibly
could on a rocco to eradicate all of
them which includes a council full of
omega level mutants he did it in 20
minutes 20 minutes he killed them all
every single one of them now here's the
crazy thing we get this like amazing
monologue right we're basically told
daddy rayno's uses the remaining time
well right t minus 60 minutes right the
hour is over and it says so is 98 of all
life in a 50 mile radius all these guys
are basically dead right uranus leaves
satisfied he is supremely confident in
his ability to bring death in all the
ages he has never felt the need to check
his work in this he is foolish he has
spent the last hour on the planet
morocco and on a rocko you always make
sure and so one of the things that
happens is we actually end up finding
out that lotus logos had basically
survived now it wasn't just him and in
fact he's told by some disembodied voice
forgive me right like i had to hide you
i had to hide you and keep you protected
because you're the person that i have to
keep alive in order to help me and so in
response to this lotus says he
challenged all of us we cannot yield nor
die too quickly this way i fight again
and take revenge for the bones that are
all laid here for all the people that
uranus killed i am going to get revenge
and the response here is no right do not
do that at the moment we have to be
alive we have to marshal our forces we
have to find a way to strike back if we
do that now we will all perish we have
to unify and we have to bring an end to
all of this because literally logos is
just like okay so ora serrata is maimed
only right her eye is injured in time
she can be healed and her power can be
restored and he says she has survived
much worse but her weapon will require
healing and your reynos's weapons will
roam unchecked we must strategize and
the response here is
no right such strategies are not the
place for you right you are not the one
running the show here anymore in the end
i am the one who sits at the seat of
loss and the seat of loss now seizes
control because this is a war and it's a
war that we are losing so if we are
going to win we have to follow a
strategy that i have devised literally
magneto survived having his heart ripped
out now this is the power of magneto as
an omega level mutant this guy what it
looks like he's doing here because we're
not giving a definitive explanation this
guy literally looks like he's
controlling the iron in his blood to
keep his blood flowing to keep his blood
pumping so his body can function because
remember once the heart's gone there's
nothing to pump blood throughout the
body and so literally your organs your
brain you don't get the blood you need
and then you ultimately die but while
magneto manipulating the iron in his
blood and keeping his blood flowing he
keeps himself alive that's the power of
this guy this dude has no heart in his
chest it's been ripped out of his body
and he's keeping himself going not only
that there's two things to take away
from this the first is that magneto is a
master strategist i mean you're talking
about a guy who has at different points
in time over the course of his
publication history taken on any
combination of the inhumans which don't
really matter because he and humans suck
the avengers the other x-men and even
eternals and has won he's done it
several times over this guy is a monster
not only that he controls the entirety
of the electromagnetic spectrum what we
saw here is a taste of the full power
magneto has and the reason for that is
the second thing magneto is pissed and
you talk to anybody out there who knows
anything about magneto and they will
tell you man they will turn your son
when magneto gets pissed oh dude when
magneto gets angry that's when the war
just begins with that being said guys
we're bringing this video to an end
thank you all for watching and i will
catch you all later
peace